"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" is blowing
up movie theaters like Rocket and one of his
moon-destroying weapons. And there are plenty
of very good reasons for its deserved success.
One of the biggest factors that weighed
on the release of "Ant-Man and The Wasp:
Quantumania" was the fact that it hit a wall of
negative critical reviews before it even reached
its opening night. In contrast, "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3" was buzzing the moment
the early screenings started. To be clear, some
reviews were a mixed bag. But that didn't matter.
The overwhelming message from early viewers was
simple: Vol. 3 is one of the MCU's crown jewels.
The warm early reception paved the way for viewers
to flock to the cinemas to see if the critics were
right. With so much buzz over the long-awaited
third installment, the strong initial response
confirmed that everyone needed to get to a
theater to see the space spectacle for themselves.
There's one significant external
factor that guaranteed that the
third "Guardians" film would succeed at
the box office: There was very little
competition. James Gunn's third and final
MCU installment arrived in cinemas with
evergreen movies populating screens and
no major tentpole film on the horizon.
"Guardians of the Galaxy: Vol. 3" came out
on May 5th. "The Super Mario Bros. Movie"
came out on April 5th. Despite
release dates one month apart,
"Super Mario" was still the runner-up at the box
office on Quill and company's opening weekend.
"Look at us. We're adorable!"
The pair was distantly followed
by other less popular options,
like "Evil Dead Rise," "Are You There God?
It's Me, Margaret," and newcomer "Love Again."
Other cinematic runs were also still playing,
including "John Wick: Chapter
4" and "Dungeons and Dragons:
Honor Among Thieves," which goes to show how slim
the options were on the first weekend of May 2023.
And the second-place competition from
the still-overperforming "Mario" only
brought in $18.6 million, less than a sixth of the
galactic-sized total domestic haul of "Guardians."
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3" came
out in early May, right in the middle
of spring. But the trailers billed the film
as an early summer blockbuster. The truth is,
summer blockbusters don't care about hard
calendar dates. Warm weather is here. Summer
break is right around the corner. Vacations
are on the calendar. The summer movie season
has arrived, and the third "Guardians"
installment capitalized on that fact.
The argument goes back and forth about whether the
summer box office is all it's cracked up to be,
and the 2023 summer slate is certainly a
mixed bag. There are plenty of tentpole
films and indie alternatives coming to
theaters in the coming months, but the
post-pandemic theatrical slump continues to dog
cinemas, making any summer success questionable.
Still, "Guardians 3" managed to pull
some of that summer box office magic
into Spring. The result was a film
billed as kicking off the supposedly
impending "summer swell," which certainly
didn't hurt the movie's must-see appeal.
The theatrical experience isn't what
it used to be. Before the pandemic,
going to the movies was a common activity
regardless of what movie titles were up on
the marquee. But the entire pastime came to a
screeching halt in 2020 due to the pandemic.
Since quarantines and social
distancing requirements have lifted,
theaters have had a slow and painful return
to normalcy. Even then, the "new normal"
for theaters is hardly reminiscent of the
old one. Packed auditoriums are rare and
only tend to happen when there is a truly
big movie that will attract an audience.
"Guardians of the Galaxy: Vol. 3" fits the
bill of a genuine tentpole film in a way that
few others can. It's a large-scale story with
A-list talent and glittering special effects
that concludes the story of a top property in an
already wildly successful cinematic universe. By
post-pandemic theatrical standards, "Guardians of
the Galaxy: Vol. 3" was simply too big to fail.
"Guardians of the Galaxy: Vol. 3" is worth
watching for the emotional story it tells.
But plenty of external factors had viewers
ready to watch it as soon as possible. One
of the most prominent of these was
watching James Gunn's MCU swan song.
As the veteran director prepares to reboot
Superman as part of his DC-focused future,
fans were ready to flock to see his final
directorial moments in Marvel's universe.
The emotions were even higher for fans
who remembered Gunn's sudden dismissal
from the franchise back in 2018 and his
even more abrupt rehiring two years later.
Since Gunn's reinstatement, fans
have anxiously waited to see what
he would cook up for his last hurrah
in the MCU, and he didn't disappoint.
Back in 2014, the unexpectedly emotional story
of the first "Guardians of the Galaxy" captured
the hearts of diehard and fairweather
fans alike. The success of the first
film was so great that it competed with
obvious blockbusters like "The Avengers"
in the hearts and minds of MCU audiences. Its
sequel, while less popular, still built on the
existing narrative, simultaneously creating
more laughs and greater emotional stakes.
"We were always searching for a
family until we found each other."
During the extended lull between the second and
third franchise films, the bumbling-but-heroic
group got tangled up in the "Infinity War" affair
with the Avengers, where they lost Gamora and saw
half of their crew snapped into thin air. They
went through even more harrowing adventures in
"Avengers: Endgame" before making a brief
pit stop in Thor's fourth franchise film.
Then they set the stage for "Vol. 3" with the
Disney+ Christmas special released in late 2022.
From their spunky origins to a
Christmas-light-infused romp on
Knowhere with Kevin Bacon, this ragtag team
of heroes has seen it all. The fact that their
third standalone film was heavily billed as the
original group's last outing and the final chapter
of their story made it an automatic trip to the
theater on opening weekend for countless fans.
The MCU is in the midst of a seismic shift. The
first three phases of the cinematic universe,
collectively billed as the "Infinity Saga,"
officially ended in the wake of the conflict
with Thanos. Since then, Phase 4 struggled to
recapture the magic of the first wave of Marvel
movies. New heroes were introduced in isolated
stories that only occasionally overlapped with the
larger narrative. In addition, the use of Disney+
limited series alongside full-length feature films
disrupted and accelerated the traditionally
slow build-up of past MCU storytelling.
Phase 5 has begun, with Kang looming and many
crossovers in store. Yet the transition from the
classic Avengers to a new roster of heroes remains
shaky. That’s why a group like the Guardians of
the Galaxy is so priceless. The team links to the
past and projects into the future. A movie like
this one evokes nostalgia while also setting
up the storylines and stakes of future films.
This isn't just helpful behind the scenes.
Fans feel it too. The ability to live in the
comfort zone of past franchise experiences
while getting amped for future possibilities
gave "Vol. 3" a dual attraction that is
hard to find in the MCU at the moment.
One morbidly fascinating factor that doubtless
drew many viewers to see "Guardians of the Galaxy:
Vol. 3" on opening weekend was the
question of who was going to die.
While there are multiple death scares,
particularly for Star-Lord and Rocket, by the time
the credits roll no one from the original gang is
given their final last words. Yet the question of
which of the original gang would die was in the
air for months leading up to the film's release.
The trailers showed clips of Nebula carrying
a limp Star-Lord. Rocket is shown surrounded
by white light. There's a snapshot of Quill
screaming in grief. The signs were there,
and while they ended up being red herrings,
they motivated a lot of viewers to get off
the couch and hightail it to the nearest
big screen before they saw spoilers online.
Rocket is one of the original Guardians
of the Galaxy. He's been with the team
from the beginning when the crew bumped into
one another on Xandar. He bonded with his new
family and suffered through losing them in The
Blip. Yet despite his presence, cynical humor,
and endless devotion to his friends, we didn't
really know who the MCU's version of Rocket was.
"Or if you want to blow up moons."
"No one is blowing up moons."
"You just wanna suck the joy out of everything."
The promotional material made it clear that the
third "Guardians" movie wasn't just a send-off for
the original team, but also an homage to Rocket.
The raccoon was an underdeveloped character that
was near and dear to the director's heart. In a
2022 interview with "Entertainment Weekly," Gunn
explained his motivation for shining a spotlight
on the Guardians' smartest member. He said,
"One of the reasons why I came back to [make]
this movie was because I felt like I needed to
tell Rocket's story. I would've been very sad
not to complete the trilogy for many reasons,
but I just feel very connected to Rocket. I feel
like nobody would be able to tell
his full story if it wasn't me."
Gunn may have a special affinity for Rocket,
but there are millions of fans close behind
him. Learning the origins of everyone's
favorite Trash Panda was too good to miss.
Groot has had one of the most transformative
journeys of any MCU character. While the
stoic nature of Groot's race has remained intact
throughout the arc of his character's evolution,
the rest of him has changed
every time we've seen him.
"I am Groot!"
The original Groot from "Guardians of the
Galaxy" went down in a self-sacrificing
ball of arboreal glory as the team saved
Xandar from an Infinity Stone-wielding
Ronan the Accuser. By the end of the film, an
offshoot of the hero was growing in a planter.
In "Vol. 2," Baby Groot is dancing around
with toddler-like innocence. "Infinity War"
features a teenage Groot obsessed with himself
and uninterested in helping unless he has to.
By the "Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday
Special," Groot is looking all grown up.
One of the small-yet-significant draws of a third
"Guardians of the Galaxy" flick was the fact that
we could see where Groot is in his ever-growing
state. It turns out that we get two iterations for
the price of one. Initially, Groot is in his young
adult phase, and he remains that way for the bulk
of the movie. However, in one of the end credit
scenes, we're treated to a super-sized version of
the character. Whether he's a happy-go-lucky
sapling or a living tree, gauging where the
character is during his life cycle has become a
fun revelation with each Guardian's appearances.
Looking back, Thanos was a pretty incredible MCU
antagonist. Building up a multi-movie villain and
delivering a satisfying pay-off is hard. One-off
villains often outshine them, especially with good
writing and execution. Past big bads, like Michael
B. Jordan’s Killmonger and Cate Blanchett’s Hela,
exemplify this, and so does Chukwudi Iwuji’s High
Evolutionary in "Guardians of the Galaxy: Vol. 3."
The High Evolutionary is a detached and
lofty villain who fascinates and horrifies
all at once. While less sympathetic
than other antagonists, the character
is frightening in a cold and rational way
that makes him the stuff of nightmares.
"I'm not trying to conquer the
universe. I'm perfecting it."
Iwuji brings The High Evolutionary to life in an
incredibly believable way, with a performance that
ranks amongst the best that the MCU has given us
in years. The High Evolutionary may go down with
his planet-sized ship, but he made a big impact
in what just might be his only MCU appearance.
“Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3” may seem like a
blast from the past, but it technically belongs
to Phase 5 of the MCU. It fits squarely in
the middle of the current mega-narrative arc,
the "Multiverse Saga." True, the third film in
the series doesn’t have much to do with traversing
multiple dimensions, but it prepares the ground
for the increasingly complex storytelling ahead.
Gamora’s story illustrates this. In “Vol. 3,”
the Daughter of Thanos is not herself. In fact,
she's a past iteration of Gamora from
2014's "Guardians of the Galaxy" storyline,
transplanted several years into the future.
The original Gamora died in "Avengers:
Infinity War" at the hands of her adopted father.
"Everyone else who died in the past stayed dead,
not her. Why? Was it the
magic cliff? I don't know."
The interactions between this "reset"
Gamora and the rest of the Guardians are
a nice testing ground to explore how to tell
meaningful multiverse narratives that actually
matter. Of course, the fact that the Gamora
storyline was already teased in "Avengers:
Endgame" made it something fans were invested
in watching play out as soon as possible.